- - Alain Quittet Hangai Aline
popositive Michel Auger bonsoir.
- - Bonsoir.
- - Petit retour de table à
ChChâteauguay avec les libéraux2
vovoix, Brenda Shanahan qui est
réréélue. Ce qui fait que je vos
momontre le tableau pour le
CaCanada, les libéraux ou
anannonçant 60 ans maintenant et
leles conservateurs sont 19. Le
blbloc 32.
ReRevient pour le bloc l'Oscar e
lala dernière fois. Les libéraux
onont prient la tête, depuis un
bobout mais là ça confirmait la
didistance un peu. À leur tour e
teterre, Alec, 12 voix c'est in
exextremis mais c'est une
vivictoire.
- - Tandis que toutes les voies
cocomptent et que les gens doivt
alaller voter parce que ça peut
fafaire effectivement dans une
cicirconscription toute la
didifférence. On en a un bon
exexemple c'est assez rare qu'un
cocomptage fonctionne. Il y a
ququand même un écart important.
AvAvant de déclencher le contrat
jujudiciaire dans ce cas-ci. Il
sesemble avoir une erreur
clcléricale le directeur de
scscrutin qui avait mit le mauvs
chchiffre sur un papier après le
cocomptage.
L'L'écart était quand même
susubstantiel et on a un bon
prprocessus si on a réussi à
rerecompter toutes les voies,
ququ'on a fait travail
ququi a même des jours et deux
sesemaines plus tard on est en
memesure de déclarer un nouveau
vavainqueur. Le système fonctioe
plplutôt bien. Madame Shanahan
mimilitait de l'emporter. Dozoi,
çaça a passé très proche.
CÇa passé proche qu'elle perd sn
sisiège.
- - Et les libéraux sont bien
cocontents ce soir Hélène quand
mmême.
- - Oui certainement quoi que vs
l'l'avez mentionné, le partage s
sisièges au Québec se retrouve
exexactement le même que celui n
202019. On se retrouve avec le
mmême équilibre.
AÀ 160 ne change pas grand-chose
ilil manque encore des sièges vs
lala majorité. On encore la même
dydynamique, d'alliance qu'on
popourrait faire avec le NPD ou
avavec le bloc.
J'J'imagine que Monsieur O'Haraa
reregarder les listes électorals
etet allez y trouver chacun de s
amamis qui n'ont pas été votés.l
enen passe un savon parce qu'il
vivient de perdre une belle job.
- - Michel C. Auger, coup de
chchapeau système qui est quand
mmême minutieux. Ça se fait dans
lele bon ordre.
- - On compte encore aux États-
UnUnis je vous fais remarquer. t
ilil raconte, mais ça c'est pare
quque M. Trump a un problème.
MaMais 12 voix d'avance, c'est n
vovote qui change pour chaque 25
bubureaux de scrutin.
C'C'est la plus mince des marges
mamais il reste encore un comté
dodont on ne connaît pas le
rérésultat. Il y a un comptage.u
lala candidate libérale, ça ausi
leles libéraux vont regarder
sasavaient beaucoup d'attention.
- - Très bien bon Monsieur Trudu
onon disait le haut début avec
MaMadeleine, on a tellement paré
pependant la campagne, il fallat
quque ça arrive vite.
LeLes vaccinations obligatoires
popour les fonctionnaires 257 00
pepersonnes qui s'touchent. Fin
ococtobre et mi-novembre, date-
bubutoir avant de ne plus pouvor
trtravailler étant en congé sans
sosolde.
EsEst-ce que c'était, Hélène
didisait ici, d'abord ce n'était
papas une surprise. Est-ce que
c'c'était nécessaire d'après vo?
- - On peut quand même
s's'interroger parce que les
fofonctionnaires fédéraux ne sot
papas nécessairement des gens qi
trtravaillent beaucoup avec le
pupublic.
LaLa très grande majorité d'ente
eueux sont encore en télétravai.
C'C'est d'ailleurs une
prpréoccupation des syndicats qi
rereprésentent les fonctionnairs
féfédéraux.
IlIls ne le disent pas très
fofortement parce qu'il semble
bibien que l'opinion publique et
d'd'accord avec le gouvernement
esest d'accord avec cette mesur.
DoDonc il semble qu'ils ne sont
papas très populaires à vouloir
dédéfendre le droit de leurs
memembres.
NéNéanmoins ils ont un malaise
paparce que ce qu'il réclamait,
LeLeskinen une forme de gradatin
quque par exemple une infirmière
ququi travaillerait auprès de
popopulations autochtones dans e
nonord par exemple que oui, ell,
elelles ont l'obligation de
vavacciner par exemple mais peu-
êêtre pas le préposé au brevet
ququi travail de la maison chez
lului depuis 20 ans.
OnOn aurait voulu avoir une
apapproche différenciée, ce n'et
papas au rendez-vous, mais on ne
pepeut pas crier trop fort parce
ququ'on sait que politiquement,a
nene serait pas bien passé.
- - Michel C. Auger est-ce que
popour l'exemplarité, il y a
bebeaucoup de soldes là-dedans t
dedes gens qui ne sont pas en
cocontact avec des gens.
PoPour l'exemplarité c'était pas
d'd'après vous nécessaires?
- - C'était peut-être nécessaire
popour l'exemplarité, mais je
pepense que le gouvernement
féfédéral sait magasiner une sée
dede poursuites par les gens du
bubureau des brevets et du consl
dudu trésor qui travaille en
tétélétravail dans leur sous-so.
PaParce qu'un moment donné, c'et
cece que cette situation-là va e
reretrouver devant les tribunau.
IlIl peut y avoir un sacré paqut
dede fonctionnaires qui vont se
jojoindre
lele classement est un recours
cocollectif est un peu coûté trs
chcher gouvernement. Il n'est ps
cecertain que le tribunal parlee
cece côté-là. L'exemplarité c'et
unune belle vertu,
mamais ce n'est pas dans les
coconventions collectives et ce
n'n'est pas.. quelqu'un n'a pase
cocontact avec le public qu'este
ququi justifie ça? Les tribunaux
vovont devoir trancher.
- - Alex qu'en pensez-vous?
- - Le gouvernement fédéral et s
prprovinces derrière la province
onont la possibilité d'obliger s
gegens se faire virer vacciner
fofonctionnaires ou non.
LaLa notion de santé du QuQuébec
auautorise le gouvernement dire
quque vous avez l'obligation
d'd'être vaccinés peu importe le
mémétier peu importe à la maiso.
LeLe gouvernement n'a pas activé
etet le vent fédéral de la
paparcelle non plus. Il pourrait
totout à fait l'activer le fair.
IlIl a des outils mais pour
l'l'instant il souhaitait aller
didifféremment. Il pourrait être
obobjet de l'activer
évéventuellement. Il y a une
ququestion d'exemplarité là-
dededans.
DuDu côté de Vernon vent fédéral
onon souhaite envoyer un messag:
vovous valez plus loin : notammt
vavacciner tous vos
fofonctionnaires. On le fait pas
memention des fonctionnaires. Ee
esest partie qui le réclame, le
PaParti libéral de Madame Anglae
didit que tous les fonctionnairs
dedevraient être vaccinée. Les
tétélécommunications Liverpool t
papar les zéros par institut de
veveille vacciner. Est-ce que ce
prpremier état? Je ne sais pas.
N'N'aurait pu encore aller plus
loloin.
LeLe gouvernement dit je vais
vivivre avec les poursuites, on
pepense qu'il y a quand même une
jujurisprudence qui nous permet
d'd'aller de l'avant.
- - Ça c'est pour les
fofonctionnaires, il a les voyas
auaussi. Parlons des voyages por
totout le monde. Ç'avait été tot
auaussi télégraphié et dit par
MoMonsieur Trudeau, il voulait e
dédémarquer des conservateurs.
AlAlors là il y a une certaine
cocohérence là-dedans.
- - Oui par contre il y a peut-
êêtre une difficulté pratique ax
prpratiques à mettre ça en plac.
D'D'ailleurs les compagnies
araryennes par exemple en
paparallèle sont d'accord avec a
memesure.
IlIl faut comprendre que cette
ididée de passeport vaccinal
exexiste pas l'échelle
papancanadienne.
CeCertaines provinces entendentt
d'd'autres pas. Les transports
papardon c'est pancanadien.
DoDonc il va y avoir dans chaque
prprovince des ressortissants de
n'n'importe quelles provinces qi
vovont se présenter avec son
cococuage et l'autre avec son bt
dede papier.
ToTout ça va être très diversif.
LaLa compagnie aérienne, la
cocompagnie ferroviaire va devor
élélaborer un système en très pu
dede temps.
PoPour pouvoir valider toute
épépreuve vaccinale. C'est un di
lologistique très réel.
- - A pas une preuve, un docume.
VoVous dîtes que ça renvoie à ce
quque d'autres parties demandées
auaux libéraux.
EtEt au gouvernement d'avoir une
prpreuve pancanadienne.
- - Oui absolument ce serait
prprobablement souhaitable aussi
popour les Canadiens qui vont à
l'l'étranger.
QuQui aurait peut-être une preue
unun peu plus uniforme lorsqu'on
s's'en va en France, en Allemage
auaux États-Unis a présenté dans
dedes endroits où on l'exige.
QuQue d'avoir 10, il n'y a plus
pepeur veille qui n'utilise pasa
prpreuve vaccinale,
pepeut-être une qui m'échappe, a
plplupart en ont une. Ce sont ts
dedes documents des façons de
prprocéder différentes.
OnOn devrait uniformiser tout ç.
ToTower ne prenne pas le pas sur
leles provinces,
jeje ne sais pas décrit une chae
dede compétences. Et que Ottawae
mmêle de tout ça. Je fais juste
ququ'on pourrait avoir une
papasserelle qui Fransson
ququ'on puisse télécharger la
veversion fédérale pour prendre
leles transports et à l'étrange.
- - Monsieur Trudeau a dit qu'il
alallait faire ça justement,
d'd'avoir une uniformisation por
leles voyages à l'étranger. Clay
mmême si nécessaire remboursait
leles provinces pour les frais i
onont été encourus.
C'C'est évident pour voyages à
l'l'étranger ce que ça va prende
çaça d'une façon ou d'une autre.
LoLors de retour au Canada il ya
dedes jeunes impliqués existe.
- - L'exemplarité dont on parlat
nene touche pas les députés.
LeLes députés ont une qualité ps
grgrande, c'est le droit d'êtree
ququ'ils veulent, sont élus pare
pepeuple à quelque chose de
fofondamental. Ils ne sont pas
totouchés par cette obligation s
dédéputés.
MaMais ils ne sont pas les
vovoyages. On écoute Monsieur
TrTrudeau on revient.
- - Avec les mesures que
vovous présentez aujourd'hui,
çaça veut donc dire qu'un déput,
jeje vous donne un exemple,
unun député conservateur
dede l'Alberta ne pourrait plus
prprendre l'avion pour venir
àà la Chambre des communes
àà partir de la fin d'octobre,
c'c'est bien ça?
- - Oui. Il y a plus de 80 %
dedes Canadiens qui ont fait
lala bonne chose. On en a
didiscuté longuement pendant
cecette élection.
EtEt les Canadiens ont été clais
ququ'ils s'attendent à ce que
totout le monde fasse sa part
popour se protéger.
- - Parce que les libéraux, le D
lele bloc Condie : nous nous
dédéputé sont ou serons vacciné.
AlAlors Alex, ça renvoie la
prpression du côté des
coconservateurs.
- - Oui c'est le bureau de régie
ininterne des Chambre des commus
ququi va décider si ce qui pénal
dadans la Chambre des communes
dodoivent être vaccinés.
D'D'ailleurs les employés devrot
l'l'être pour y travailler. Mais
leles députés devront s'engendrr
popour décider oui ou non cette
obobligation. D'abord le passept
vavaccinal dans la chambre des
cocommunes.
OnOn ne fait pas directement
papartir en voiture de l'Alberta
dede la Colombie-Britannique coe
unune bonne distance pour aller
sisiéger à la chambre des
cocommunes.
C'C'est moins pire si vous êtesn
dédéputé conservateur de l'Ontao
mamais souvenez de l'Alberta oue
lala Saskatchewan c'est une bone
roroute vers la chambre des
cocommunes. Mais on ne sait pas
cocombien y en a, Erin O'Toole a
jajamais voulu le dire. On n'a s
dede chiffres. Où ils sont ce qe
sasa cause des problèmes? Ou es-
cece que dans le fond de très pu
dédéputé conservateur qui ne sot
papas vaccinés. On ne le sait p.
- - Joël Denis posé la même
ququestion au chef conservateur:
ilil est revenu avec la même
cacassette la campagne Monsieur
O'O'Toole en disant : je constae
c'c'est important la vaccinatio,
mamais, mais est-ce qu'il est ps
ouou pas avec ça?
- - Oui un peu les prix.
PrProbablement qui ne veut pas
dodonner l'information parce qul
a a pas. C'est un esprit de
liliberté qui anime les
coconservateurs sur cette
ququestion. Ils estiment que oui
lala vaccination est bonne, mais
onon doit quand même défendre la
liliberté, même la liberté de
fafaire de mauvais choix.
DoDonc dans cet esprit là, de
papasser un questionnaire à tous
leles candidats, tous les déput,
cece sont un peu contraires.
IlIls n'ont probablement pas les
ststatistiques sans doute peut-
êêtre. Ceci savait un peu
didifficile
dede débusquer ces conservateurs
llà. En ce moment il y a beaucop
dede télé parlementarisme si vos
vavalez. Il y a plein de députés
KaKarachi : il faut qu'on commee
àà regarder les députés et voir
lelequel n'est pas venu à Ottawa
dedepuis combien de temps?
EsEst-ce que c'est peut-être por
dedes raisons de vaccination qui
n'n'est pas été sur la colline?
- - Qui vont pouvoir les passer
susur le radar. Mais c'est clair
quque cette affaire, c'est un
bobonus pour Monsieur Trudeau.
IlIl sait que sa politique
alallègrement populaire auprès
d'une bonne majorité de
CaCanadiens. Et en plus, ça lui
pepermet d'en titiller les
coconservateurs c'est gagnant-
gagagnant.
- - Ce qu'il a pas empêché de
s's'excuser pour autre chose;
l'l'affaire de tous finaux la
sesemaine dernière dont on a
bebeaucoup parlé.
LaLa journée où il décrète que
c'c'est une journée nationale de
vévérité et réconciliation il sn
vava, on le sait sur une plage n
unun acte finaud en Colombie-
BrBritannique.
- - Comme j'ai dit, c'était
unune erreur de choisir de voyar
cece jour-là, le 30 septembre.
EtEt je le regrette. C'était
unun moment important pour
sese recueillir en tant
quque Canadiens pour réfléchir
àà la réconciliation.
MaMais je suis content que j'aiu
paparler avec la chef Casimir
dede Kamloops pour offrir
memes excuses et pour m'engager
àà venir la visiter, à visiter
lala communauté dans les semains
àà venir.
- - Bon, Hélène rapidement toure
tatable. D'abord il s'excuse
auauprès de la chef parce qu'ily
avavait une indifférente
ininvitation inégalée.
IlIl a fait autre chose. Est-ce
quque ces dossiers clos ça va
lalaisser des traces?
- - Je ne sais pas, je pense qul
y y avait peut-être pas le choix
dede formuler ses excuses là du
fafait de la pression publique i
a a augmenté beaucoup sur lui.
MaMais moi je suis de celles qui
pepensent que cette pression est
unun peu injuste.
RaRappelons que c'était une
sesemaine de la vérité
coconciliation qui commençait le
2727 et dès le 29, la veille il
avavait le coup d'envoi de la
jojournée vérité conséquences.
- - Vous dites qu'on a charrié e
leles chroniqueurs ont charrié?
- - Je pense que oui. Il faut le
didire. Il a participé à cette
sosoirée de lancement organisé r
lele sang vérité conciliation à
OtOttawa. Il a prononcé une
alallocution il a été présent. e
n'n'est pas vrai...
- - pourquoi s'excuse alors?
- - Avait oppression politique.
MaMais je pense qu'il aurait dûe
fafaire. Je pense que son
cocomportement était correct. Il
avavait quelque chose pour
l'l'événement et ne pouvait pas
êêtre tous les jours.
- - Alex et Michel ses
coconclusions. Parce que des
chchroniqueurs reconnaissent au
CaCanada anglais il est défini
popolitiquement. Bon Alex.
- - Je pense pas que ce soit
nénécessairement le début de la
fifin. Je pense que ce n'est rae
dede jugement je ne suis pas
d'd'accord avec Hélène. Il y avt
d'd'autres moments pour aller se
prpromener sur la plage.
MaMais cette journée-là pendant
quque des cérémonies et que
cacamelot cette opinion car un
prpremier ministre avec un avion
avavec son sa disposition. Il
avavait certainement besoin avec
lala campagne triennale, ce n'et
papas ça. C'est son propre
gogouvernement qui une journée
spspéciale de réflexion et quand
lele vent vacances en même temp,
c'c'est des images extrêmement
nunuisibles politiquement.
JeJe sens qu'il voulait aller au
dedevant des questions, s'excusr
avavant qu'on lui pose la questn
papassera été vraiment la premie
ququestion. 13.
JeJe pense qu'il a bien fait de
s's'excuser je pense que c'est e
ererreur de jugement et la régin
dede Jouy s'écarte différemment.
- - C'est une erreur, surtout
ququ'on a instauré cette journé-
llà. Cela dit Monsieur Trudeau
esest bien bon dans les excuses
mamais le problème des excuses